I want you to implement such a controller.
Here is the code I've prepared for you.
There is a class robot with which you're familiar.
It has an "init." You can set the position using the function "set" as before.
There are steering_noise and distance_noise.
You're familiar with this.
There is also something called "drift," which you won't use right now,
but later on it'll become handy.
There is your move command, all the way we've implemented before.
I've improved a little bit the print out of the coordinates using floats.
I want you to implement the run command, which takes as input the control parameter
that governs the proportional response of the steering angle to the crosstrack error.
The robot has an initial position of 0, 1, and 0, a speed of 1,
and I wanted to simulate it for 100 steps.
Here is what I envision to happen.
Your robot is initially off the the x axis by 1.
I want it to drive along the x axis.
The y value is the same as the cross track error.
By turning, inversely proportional to the y value,
using a parameter tau that sets the response strength of the proportional controller.
I want the robot to turn towards the x axis, drive in that direction, overshoot,
turn around, and drive back.
To do this, simulate the world for a 800 steps, and use a proportionality term
that sets my steering angle alpha in proportion to the crosstrack error y.
Enter your code here, and when you're done with it, and you run it with the coefficient 0.1,
here's the output that I want you to produce. It's 100 lines.
You can see the robot position starting 1 off in y.
It then reduces y over time to go into negative territory.
On the right side you see this corresponding steering orientation,
and you can see as you move on the y coming back into positive territory,
and you can see how the robot overshoots slowly around the reference trajectory of the x axis.
Please go implement this.